hello and welcome back to crash course
cryosphere Tom and I have been working
very hard on getting these episodes
ready for you and we're excited to
finally release the second half of the
series now this episode you're not
actually going to see very much me this
is because the gravel monkey has decided
that he's going to hijack the entire
episode to talk about some really quite
technical stuff now to avoid this
getting confusing I've introduced the
so hopefully that will keep things
understandable this episode also
features the first in our series of
interviews with scientists who work in
the cryosphere so you got that to look
forward to but the main focus of this
video are cold and warm glaciers roll
the intro a graces thermal regime by
which we mean the temperature throughout
the glacier and in particular its bed is
one of most important factors in
controlling so glacial processes
meltwater perhaps for obvious reasons is
very client ly linked to the Fillmore
regime that the glacier is experiencing
and the availability or otherwise of it
controls processes such as debris
entrainment transport and deposition
subglacial sliding and outbursts floods
for example these sorts of factors all
have a strong influence on glacier
velocity as we previously discussed
greater velocity cannot just be
explained by creep and the processes
that I just mentioned it will look at
further now are one of the key reasons
why glaciers flow faster things to be
explained by just creep
code based glaciers are those that are
experiencing sub-zero temperatures
throughout their mass and particularly
at the bed throughout the year
no matter the season whether it's melt
season summer winter the bed of the
glacier is frozen to its substrate
underneath this means that there's no
free water at the bed of the glacier and
therefore ice creep is the primary means
by which these glaciers move and as we
mentioned a previous episode this means
these rates are limited very slow and in
addition to that relatively little
landscape alteration takes place as you
don't have water moving debris around
and helping to create features such as
Marines one based glaciers are those at
which the bed of the glacier is that the
pressure melting point for the entirety
of the year or almost all of the year
this means that there's always liquid
water at the base of the glacier whether
that's in a channel or whether in a
distributed system it's still there this
with several implications one of which
is that you're going to see an increase
in velocity of the overall ice pack
this is because the water acts as a
lubricant and due to several other
mechanisms which will come into later
this water at the bed of the Glacia
tends to form very distinctive drainage
systems which form narrow and
spectacular hydrological networks and
these networks can vary on a day to day
basis month to month season to season
and these variations in the drainage
network construction and variation can
lead to a lot of variations we see in
glacial velocity purpose most
interesting film or regime is that a
polished thermal glazes these are glazes
where the bed is both frozen and not
frozen at its to its bed this means that
water can be moving or not you can have
acceleration or D acceleration and this
creates a whole range of interesting
thermal regime patterns hydrological
patterns and velocity flow fields also
just go that's really cool you can
sometimes get really warm based glazes
which is where volcano erupts underneath
the glacier this happens to happen all
and Iceland and some of you may remember
the IFO yokel eruption which caused
chaos to air traffic throughout Europe
now the glaciers doesn't always get
completely blown through as happen in
their yokel case and instead you get
formations of lava underneath that place
here and also a large build of meltwater
this meltwater will be released
incredibly quickly and very destructive
floods core you collapse but also the
formations of lava and bedrock and so on
they're created under these glaciers
during these eruptions very similar to
some landforms we see on Mars some of
the current research frontiers is
looking at Iceland and see if we can use
that as a proxy particularly in terms of
sub Glacial volcanic eruptions for
proxies of landforms that we see on Mars
hello do you miss me there isn't
actually any point to this voiceover I
just wanted to try and contribute to the
episode and I felt like I hadn't yet
hello bat Tom he's got some more
complicated terminology for you
the glacis and ice caps that best allied
with a simple creep we discussed in
episode 5 only really exist in the hypoa
environments where cold based glaciers
dominate when these high polar glaciers
are frozen to their beds the frictional
adhesive strength is very high
however in temperate glaciers where the
bases are the pressure melting point to
other processes started dominates these
are subcostal deformation and basal
sliding whilst it has recently shown
that some basal sliding can take place
in coal based glazes it is typically
very minimal indeed has been shown that
under cold based glaciers you can
preserve the landforms of landscapes
from previous glaciations this just goes
to illustrate how low the landscape
alteration potential is of coal based
glaciation for us the most important
thing here to focus on is that the
weight of the material above an
unconsolidated bed means that that bed
experiences stress and strain that
stress and strain is imparted from the
ice above and causes the material to
deform which then helps enhance the flow
of the ice itself so I'm going to try
and demonstrate to you here is some
simple shear strain and what happens
when you put something under stress okay
so we're going to do now is just simply
apply pressure from above and then we're
going to try and watch and see what
happens to the plasticine as I apply the
pressure or moderately evenly you can
hopefully see that the layers are just
squidging together not much else is
happening
they're just compacting that's simple
pressure follow puff here comes the
second test and what going to do here is
apply some slip whilst also applying
pressure from above slip means you've
got movements in one direction now as we
slip here with pressure from above we
should hopefully share the sediments so
as we share them we'll see the layers
being sheared across I try and apply
this now yes I don't if you can see that
but what's happening at the bottom here
is that the green plasticine which is
that the rear of the direction of slip
is putting full-up is being pulled up
and forward into the orange layer it's
just about starting so I'm going to try
and give it a bit more welly and see if
I can get a slightly better effect so
I'll actually doing now is I'm cheating
slightly are now introducing pressure as
an angle which is of course having a
greater effect and it was just putting
simple shear from above all of the
levels so
oh how I wish you a rougher mr. perspex
it's just your camera I take another
break now for my exertions hopefully you
can see that we're now really getting
some smearing of material from the green
layer up into the orange you can
hopefully see how the green material is
being pulled up and folded into the
orange plasticine in case of the orange
here because if Green is not upstanding
from the plasticine it has become part
of that material because you have
pressure being applied from above along
with slip creating sheer with two
impermeable materials the green material
can't escape anywhere when it could
switch out slightly sideways which is
what it's doing but The Critic can't
escape and it's being shared into the
orange material it's not above the
orange layer hopefully you can see that
these layers are perfectly flat on top
the green is not upstanding from the
orange the green has been effectively
pushed and built into the orange
material creating this lovely sheer
structure a couple of different models
have been proposed to explain how this
deformation takes place one of these is
the Bolton high Marsh model another one
is the cool on plastic model these are
both quite advanced models and concepts
so we won't go into them here but I
suggest that it's a good place for
interested people to do more reading now
to give you a break from the science we
have our first interview with a real
scientist who works with the cryosphere
and in this video we're talking about
landscapes they've been carved out by
glaciers but are underwater
my name is dr. christine bachelor I'm a
research fellow here at has got Polar
Research Institute my wife is concerned
with Glacia and ice sheet reconstruction
so I look at the past extent and
dynamics of ice masses in order to
better understand how they're working at
the moment and how they're likely to
behave in the future so I didn't get the
chance to study glaciers and ice sheets
at school I first encountered them
during my undergraduate studies here in
Cambridge I really enjoyed the
dissertation container of the course and
my undergraduate agent involved
reconstructing the extended small area
in South Wales during the non planar
schedule around twelve eleven thousand
years
I enjoyed this film web component so
much I stayed on to do a masters and a
PhD it's got period of these sessions
sheet and they continue to be a junior
research fellow at Cambridge where I
conduct my own research on a daily basis
and also do quite a lot
teaching for the university we only have
direct measurements of the cryosphere
the past 50 to 100 years my research
seeks to put the changes that we know
about during these short time scale in
their longer-term context my research is
also motivated by trying to understand
the processes that take place a better
the glacial ice sheet this is a region
which is really difficult to access
directly so an easier to look to the
record of where glaciers and ice sheets
used to be in order to understand how
sediment eroded transported and prompted
by ice my research is focused mainly on
analyzing evidence of past locations
preserved in the marine environment
you do have landforms preserved from
past glaciations on land many of you
would have seen these such as an arrange
that you're walking in upton regions of
the UK however the terrestrial landscape
can become a brilliant by weathering and
human activity it's often better
therefore to look around walls that are
preserved in the marine environment in
areas where places used to be that are
now under sea in order to analyze the
marine environment we know research
cruises and these three main methods
first of all we use symmetry which is a
way of measuring the depth of the sea
floor to build up maps of the landforms
that are preserved there secondly the
use of boredom profiling and seismic
reflection data to analyze the sediments
that are preserved beneath the surface
of the sea floor and thirdly we use
sediment cores in order to extract
sediments beneath the seafloor and bring
it back up to the lab to analyze my
research has involved going on a
research cruise to Antarctica I was on
the James Clark Ross research vessel
which is due to be replaced in 2019 by
the David Attenborough research base the
most challenging part about fieldwork is
dealing with being on a research vessel
in rough seas whilst trying to analyse
interpret the data itself I'm down in
Antarctica during the summit waves of
24-hour sunlight so it actually becomes
quite difficult to sleep and there's
always the risk of sunburn which isn't
something people usually think about
when they go to Antarctica my favorite
part of going research cruising is the
environments that you get to see and the
animals that you encounter when I was
down in Antarctica
I got to see LM steel and a daily
penguin this is an expansion of the type
of maps we make based on the depths of
seafloor
it's called bathymetric map the IPTV is
part of agreement ice sheet and the
plume bed colors where they're shallower
water around 100 to 200 meters and the
bluer colors are where the waters down
to around 600 meters they're from data
such as this we can see the depth of the
signal it's launched the modern gauges
which is important for how they're
likely to retreat we can also analyze
the landforms that are preserved on the
seafloor when I spectacles the Glasair
ice sheet thank yous can sometimes
scratching to see both elements creating
features we call iceberg killed plow
marks an example since our mark is
showing this bathymetric image iceberg
claw marks can be 10 meters of the same
deep and up to hundreds of meters across
this image show you the series of quite
small Plummer cut by this one much
larger flower mark another I think
features such as this preserved of sea
froth can tell us about the size of the
past ice map and they can also tell us
about past oceanographic conditions that
we operating at the tiny icebergs were
drifting around we'll be including more
interviews with scientists in the coming
episodes now it's back to Tom and you'll
finally get a chance to see me working
with him in an experiment well he's also
going to go on to talk about mine notes
he's going to talk about a PhD thesis no
one's going to make it through this
episode when we move to a hard bedrock
setting by which we typically mean a
crystalline bedrock such as granite
which is not to form or break up that
easily under the way to the glaze yet
there's some slightly different
processes start to come in here
most of the drag experience comes from
frictional drag from material embedded
in the base of the glacier from form
drag which is the drag of the surface on
the
ice moving over the surface of the
bedrock the two primary mechanisms which
create basal sliding here are enhanced
creep and regulation regulation is the
process by which melting is Hantz
upstream of an obstacle this is because
of the ice comes down and it hits an
obstacle on the upstream side the
pressure is increased and when you
increase pressure more melting can take
place we can actually demonstrate this
really well with a wire nice block
demonstration which I'll get my
glamorous assistant to come in and help
me with now so luckily my glamorous
assistant has now arrived as if by magic
and now we're going to demonstrate
regulation using this wire and this ice
block now hopefully what we're going to
see here is that as the wire is applied
to the top of the ice even though it's
insulated from the heat of my hand by
the tape here it will start to sink into
the ice this is because the pressure
exerted by the wire will cause melting
now my glamorous assistant ever happy to
he'll ever have it help could you hold
the ice block yep in this sort of
position I can model that I can model it
yeah I'm not yeah let's go for that
little around you know other way around
yet have a hand there sips bigger right
now let's try this let's see if this
works and hopefully we get it longest if
I'm strong enough here we go okay there
we go
pull it oh yeah it's not a confusion so
what we're trying to simulate here with
Mick success is the effect of increasing
the pressure on a small surface on a
block of ice and it is very slowly
because it's quite a thin wire that's
probably soft so I'm pulling it I'm
losing energy as the wire stretches but
luckily my glamorous assistant has guns
now if the wire was a bit wider and a
bit rougher and a bit less stretchy
which would probably be going in quite a
bit quicker how far we got in there a
little bit a little bit so as we're
putting in at the corners where we can
actually exert enough pressure I'm going
to really put on it now and let's see
how it goes you are stronger than you
look
another complete waste of all to do
and we break okay do we split yes help
figure okay so we call that one there
and if we go to the close car we can
actually see that the Y of one very
slowly sinking in obviously this is not
the best demonstration ever because
turns out y's a bit too soft for the
purpose we intended but hopefully you
get the idea perhaps creep isn't Hans
tent enhance creep because the strain
rate of ice varies non linearly with the
applied stress this means that upstream
of obstacles where you have a higher
stress level creep is more enhanced than
it is elsewhere and therefore ice
deforms very efficiently around an
obstacle effectively accelerating the
ice as it moves over the obstacle if we
now draw the graph of enhanced creep and
regulation on the same axis we can now
see that these two processes have a
point at which they meet this is called
the controlling obstacle size and it's
the point at which efficiency is only
lost if the obstacle size increases this
means there's a point at which the
roughness of a bed will enhance the flow
of the ice more than any other this
relationship between the two actually
crops up in my PhD thesis and ended up
being quite an important part of it
because it turns out that when you look
at the landscape that's left behind you
can see this controlling obstacle size
taking place or least that's my
hypothesis my argument basically is the
glaciers actually have a positive
feedback system at the base of their
beds which means that they tend towards
efficiency you tend to get a more
efficient bed and a more efficient bed
is actually a slightly rough bed not too
big not too small just right
water cavities also play an important
role in basal sliding because they help
to govern how attached and how coupled
the glacier is to its bed water cavity
is also important in basal sliding as
they govern the degree of coupling
between the bed and the ice and are
given the threshold pressure are you in
the water cavities are growing and
expanding
they were acts to separate the glacier
from its bed this has the effect of
reducing the frictional drag all the
little bits of stuff stuck in the bottom
of the glacier and no longer in contact
with it
bet this means the glaciers sliding will
increase and consequently whole glacier
velocity would increase as well other
this essential basal duplication effect
that the cavities have there are two
more important means by which this
cavity expansion affects basal
velocities the first of these is the
hydraulic jack mechanism whereby
pressure is increased at the top of the
cavity and therefore increases literally
jacks downstream this increase in
pressure also has an effect in terms of
the third reason which is by increasing
the pressure in some areas and therefore
lifting the base off you suddenly drop
pressure to zero and pressures increase
in other areas where the ice is still in
contact in these areas where the ice is
still in contact of course you slip more
enhanced creep because we discussed
earlier
it varies not linearly therefore not
only by reducing pressure in some areas
you accelerate by reducing that pressure
and increasing it consequently in others
you increase accelerations there as well
so overall rates of glacier motion a
control of our combination of local and
non-local factors these factors can
combine in perhaps unexpected ways and
this is what results in rapid responses
glaciers to climate change and water
input this episode we covered that the
speed of which a glacier flows is
determined by a combination of factors
that work in addition to the velocity
derived from ice creep these being its
thermal regime Mount water and sub
glacial defamation that's the thermal
regime of a glacier is the temperature
experienced by the ice at its BET worn
based glaciers typically have meltwater
present cheeser doing at the pressure
melting point and therefore flow faster
coal-based glaciers on the other hand
are frozen to their bed and that glacier
flow is enhanced differently depending
on whether or not the glacier is located
on a hard bed or a soft bed unlike
brexit these two hard and soft types are
well defined
thank you for watching crash course
cryosphere if you have any questions
about the stuff we've talked about this
week then in the comments Tom and I will
be clearing up any misconceptions to two
hours after this video is released so
have a question get down there equally
if you'd like to learn more about
anything we talked about this week there
are lots of links to references and
further reading in the description
we'd like to thank you for watching and
also all of these people the healthy
make this series possible and in
particular the recover project at x2
University for helping us with funding
and the Scott Polar Research Institute
in Cambridge where we are now for being
so accommodating and helping us in
basically every way thank you so much
guys we'll see you next week